Let's do a psychology experiment.
Let's show our audience has seen
consisting of eight shots in the story
it tells is suspicious,
but a little ambiguous and open to
interpretation of girls in her
apartment.
When a guy walks suspiciously past her
window,
she goes outside to check it out.
After the video,
we ask our audience a couple open ended
questions and see what they think about
it.
How did it make them feel?
Did they like it?
Did they not like it?
Stuff like that.
Now let's show that same video to a
different audience,
but change one thing,
mirror every shot,
so now any movement left to right
becomes right to left.
The question is,
does this edit change anything?
Just character direction,
effect how the audience perceives the
character or the entire scene as a
whole.
The answer is yes and a lot more than
you think,
but why does it matter which way he
went?
To understand why direction change is so
important.
We have to talk about the three axes of
movement.
There are three directions.
Onscreen of character can move right and
left up and down and forward and
backward the direction a character moves
matters in a scene.
Moving towards the camera shows power
domination and aggression and moving
away shows weakness.
Similarly,
characters being looked down on appear
weak and high up characters are much
more dominant.
Rabbi you
our these two explanations make sense.
Of course,
someone low and far away from the camera
will be perceived differently from
someone high up and close,
but
the final character movement,
lateral movement going from right to
left is a lot less obvious.
What makes one side of the screen
different from the other?
Why does movement right to left matter?
The answer comes from time and language
in western culture.
Left to right indicates the progression
of time our language reads from left to
right.
Books began from the left and finished.
Once we get to the right in video games,
play your start on the left side and
finished the level on the right.
On any line.
Graph time increases as we move right in
our everyday life.
Movement towards the right indicates
time,
progress and normality and movement
towards the left indicates moving back
in time,
abnormality and regression from this
thinking came the theory amongst film
scholars that people will interpret left
to right movement as more natural and
normal than right to left movement
because of how our brains naturally
process moving images and this idea of
time and normality in left to right
movement gets applied in a variety of
films,
for example,
Lord of the rings maintains its left to
right movement during the journey from
the Shyer to mount doom.
Left right.
Movement is maintained during the big
travel shots and it's a subtle visual to
indicate the clear goal to reach a
specific destination.
Compare that clear objective to the last
scene in full metal jacket.
It consists of two shots,
one shot of soldiers moving left to
right past burning buildings,
and another shot of them moving right to
left with burning buildings still in the
background to be abrupt.
Lateral direction change makes it look
as if they randomly switched directions
and it gives the implication of the
soldiers are wandering aimlessly.
Stanley Kubrick uses lateral direction
change to make some commentary about the
army's unclear objectives and perhaps
commentary on the Vietnam war as a
whole.
Lateral character movement can also tell
a story in one scene,
in full metal jacket,
soldiers move to the right towards some
combat zone.
Offscreen and wounded soldiers get
carried away from the combat zone.
Moving from the right side to the left,
there's a subtle visual reinforcement
here that were the soldiers headed.
Offscreen is where men get brought back,
wounded it.
This lateral technique is similarly done
subtly in platoon and saving private
Ryan.
Wait,
sir.
What you can do so left to right is
observed as positive,
progressive and normal,
or at least that's what many film
theorists assumed.
It's only in the last five years or so
that researchers started empirically
testing lateral movement.
In 2012,
Cleveland State University conducted an
experiment by showing a sequence of
eight shots to a group of people.
They showed the exact same shots to
another group of people,
but reversed all left to right movement
to right to left movement.
Each group answered several specific
questions and several open ended ones.
About how they felt after watching the
results confirmed what many film
theorists had assumed,
but had never had any hard evidence to
prove the experimenters analyzed open
ended questions for key words.
For example,
24 point eight percent of responders
used anxious,
nervous,
uneasy,
suspenseful to describe the video.
And 11 point nine percent said fearful,
frightened,
or scared.
The most statistically significant
difference between the two groups was
what the experimenters called the
negative effect.
Similar phrases including didn't like
the clip,
liked the clip,
good,
bad,
interesting,
boring,
and strong and weak were the phrases
that different the most between the two
videos.
So for the left to right video members
consistently used words like good,
interesting and strong,
while the ones who saw or right to left
use words like bad,
boring,
and weak audiences,
perceived left to right movement
positively and right to left movement
negatively.
This study provides a huge opportunity
for filmmakers by something as simple as
switching character movement.
A director can instill a negative or
positive emotional response on the
audience,
but it seems some directors have already
caught onto this difference in left to
right and right to left,
going as far back as Alfred Hitchcock,
Alfred Hitchcock.
Stranger on a train opens with the
protagonist and antagonist showing only
their feet and legs walking.
They walk towards each other as if to
imply their paths will eventually cross.
If our study is true and left to right,
movement is perceived as more positive
than right to left.
Then this opening scene has already
subconsciously established that the
right to left character is an antagonist
and the left to right character is a
protagonist,
so not only can left right indicate a
progression of time,
it can even indicate something positive
or negative.
Roger Ebert fully supported the idea
himself as he explains in his 2008
article how to read a movie.
Roger Ebert goes further to say even the
left and right sides of the screen are
perceived as either more positive or
more negative.
I character on the right fields more
positive and in control.
While the one on the left seems weaker,
perhaps more sinister.
This is a common recurring theme,
right?
Good left bad,
and various filmmakers use this
technique.
Still smarting from.
Oh,
come on,
come on.
Yeah.
Infinity Ebert
makes the claim that these conventions
of right and left extend beyond our
language and culture.
He says that in all his years of
watching movies,
Asian cinema uses similar left versus
right techniques,
and the study supported this belief,
religious belief,
right or left hand numbness and race all
did not significantly affect the
audience's perception of lateral
movement.
Of course,
there are no absolutes in filmmaking and
sometimes what's contrary to the rule
works just as well,
but either way,
this study shows that there really is a
difference between left and right in the
film.
It's only so recently that any empirical
testing on film techniques has actually
been conducted.
Roger Ebert claims while convincing.
We're only speculation at the time,
but have now been proven to an extent.
I contacted Cleveland State University,
the ones who publish this study,
and they're still currently conducting
experiments,
testing film theories on audience
members.
It's really exciting to see that even
after 100 years,
we're still learning new things about
filmmaking to this day,
what it was.
One speculation has now been followed up
with concrete evidence,
so the next time a character crosses the
screen,
ask yourself,
thanks for watching.
I wanted to clarify the video experiment
that I show isn't the original video
experiment.
The original one hasn't been published
yet.
It hasn't been posted,
although they published the article.
They haven't posted the video that they
used,
so I just took what they talked about it
in the article and I recreated it.
I encourage you guys to look at the
original article.
It's amazing.
It goes very in depth.
Talks about things.
I didn't talk about Lincoln in the
description.
Also,
I talk about film theorists in the video
and I don't refer to specific names,
but really I'm referring to coolest
shop.
He's the man.
He's been doing all this film theory
stuff.
I'm in the seventies.
He was coming up with these three axes
of movement theory and how people
interpret movement in film and so I
encourage you to look him up.
I'm going to add some of his writing and
the description as well.
Thanks guys.